sure I got to start by saying that coat  is awesome it really is amazing it's  like there's a gunfighter that came to  town  Scizor and he's selling weed no it's  really it's really fantastic it's it's a  Gucci very nice I don't get to what is  this now what's happening right you know  flu season okay wow what an off-putting  comedy right away I had a flu shot can I  have a little more of that is this  really than I thought it was a cologne  and then I smelled it  no it's most pretty good no it really  doesn't I gotta be honest with you I  think I miss Layla I'm going yeah  sometimes I use it quite often sometimes  after I touch myself I even spray a  little bit good to know that's good that  jacket probably hiding that pretty well  yeah oh I see you didn't like what you  got there he's on to me well I'll just  talk to Conan  you